[Music]
lady gaga
praises madonna there is no real safety
except self-belief and an understanding
that i am not the owner of my talents
I'm not the owner of anything everything
I have is a gift from God and even the
things that happened to me this still
happened to me are also gifts to teach
me lessons and make me stronger
Maja's speech at the 2016 Billboard
women and music event apparently struck
a chord with the jo-ann singer she
posted this message to Twitter after
watching the moment quote inspiring
you're so brave and strong thanks for
being that for us girls we need that
it's great to to come here and to
receive this award but more importantly
to speak about women in music and women
in general in the world today very
important time we are loving seeing this
love especially after what the ladies
have said about each other in the past
they want to know what you think about
Lady gaga
it feels reductive is that good look it
up Madonna and I are very different I
wouldn't make that comparison at all I
play a lot of instruments I write all my
own music I spent hours and hours a day
in the studio I'm a producer I'm a
writer
you know there are major differences
between me and her and I don't mean that
in a disrespectful way it was absolutely
entitled to study yeah I just will not
be compared to anyone anymore I am who
the I am and this is me
you